hi there today we are discussing the
swin transformer swin stands here for
shifted windows and is basically a
vision transformer variant but with a
hierarchical way of processing the image
so if you're curious about this vision
transformer beast reportedly beating
many benchmarks grab a cup of coffee
because it is time for an ai coffee
break speaking of motivation for the
swim transformer reading this part of
the abstract triggered me a little bit
it's about the challenges in adapting
transformer from language to vision and
the others say they arise from
differences between the two domains such
as large variations in the scale of
visual entities and the high resolution
of pixels in images compared to words in
text
this is such a computer vision
researcher thing to say everything is
big data if you're brave enough words in
text can become too many too if one
wants to handle a complete dostoevsky
novel as one single data point but yes
point taken from the authors here that
there are more images in this world than
novels so funnily while transformers
with linearly scaling attention can
handle entire novels as one sequence
there are not enough novels written to
create significant data sets in this way
so yeah text transformers usually work
with smaller sequences and text is
usually processed at a sentence level
anyway back to the swin transformer here
it is based on vit and to remember how
the vision transformer works you can
check out our video on this because here
we're going to put it in a nutshell the
image is decomposed into 16 by 16 pixel
patches then these patches are
transformed into patch vectors by a
linear transformation these patch
vectors combined with positional
embeddings are processed by a
transformer in the same way in which the
transformer processes word vectors which
we also discussed in the previous video
but there is a problem with the vision
transformer that the authors here try to
alleviate with the swin transformer the
problem is related to the extraction of
patches a step which is particular to
images not to text if the image is let's
say 256 by 256 pixels then extracting 16
by 16 pixel patches would lead to 16
patches thus 16 image vectors would form
a sequence but an image of 1920 by 1920
pixels would already lead to
image vectors which is still okay with
bigger and bigger gpus of course and if
we do this to solve tasks where looking
at 16 pixel patches is not too coarse
then vit is still okay and this is the
case for tasks that are in a sense
summarizing the image like it's the case
with image classification where the goal
is to predict one label for the entire
image analyzing the image through big
patches is not that problematic here but
there are tasks where one really needs
detailed information at pixel level not
patches such a task is semantic
segmentation where the algorithm needs
to decide for each single pixel in the
image what class this belongs to in this
case 16 by 16 pixel patches are way too
big so ideally we would handle every
pixel as a token but this would quickly
become infeasible for example a 256 by
256 pixel image would already require a
transformer handling sequence length of
over 63 000 tokens a full hd image of
1920x1080 would require already a
sequence length of over 2 million this
is not scalable and we can completely
forget scaling up native deep learning
processing to 4k images who is crazy
enough to even want to do that anyway so
now we've seen that vit first splits up
the image into patches in order to keep
the sequence length within computational
bounds but this is problematic for tasks
that require detailed processing of
every pixel so let's look at how the
swing transformer wants to tackle this
problem the swin transformer still
relies on patches but instead of
choosing one size and sticking with it
the swing transformer first starts with
small patches for the first transformer
layer then merges them into bigger ones
in the deeper transformer layers this
reminds of something miss coffee bean
yeah of unit and convolution but let's
not get distracted here so the swing
transformer takes in the image and
splits the image into four by four
patches each patch is still a colored
image with three channels so a patch has
a four by four by three equals 48
feature dimensionality which is then
linearly transformed to a dimensionality
c of our choice so the only difference
to vit so far is that the patches are
smaller but what about the size c and
what does it mean well c determines the
capacity or the size of our transformer
model so you maybe know that there is a
bird base text model which has a
dimensionality of 768 for the vector
representation well in that case c is
768. there is also a bird large with c
equals
1024. c is the capacity of the model
because it determines the parameter size
or the amount of hidden units in the
fully connected layers over here just to
get an impression about the swint
transformer for swin tiny c is 96 and
192 for swin large but where were we at
this wind transformer that has divided
the image into initial 4x4 pixel patches
and a linear transformation converting
each patch into a c dimensional vector
transformer blocks process these patch
vectors but not with the usual
quadratically scaling attention but with
the shifted window based self-attention
introduced by the authors this is just a
fancy name for saying that the attention
span is limited over m patches here too
so now instead of attention one patch
does not communicate with all other
patches but only with m neighbors
i'm so sure that i saw this window
limited self attention before in another
paper under a different name miss coffee
bin do you remember where no i'll ask
the audience then if you saw this kind
of attention before or something very
similar to it then please let us know in
the comments where
it was probably an nlp paper okay in any
case the limited attention window
basically simulates for let's say this
first image patch token here that the
rest of the sequence that is not in its
aim neighborhood basically disappeared
this means that instead of quadratically
scaling a tension computation with the
sequence length we now have something
linear for small m great so now it is
time to move further to the next layer
in the hierarchy here the output of a
sequence of n patch vectors is of course
again n vectors because the transformer
is sort of an auto encoder now the
output is merged by a so-called merging
layer this concatenates the vectors of
groups of two by two neighboring patches
in the image not in the sequence as it
is quite simplistically visualized here
so from four of these c dimensional
vectors we now have one
four times c dimensional vector and this
is passed through a linear layer which
is basically a linear dimensionality
reducer from four c to two c dimensions
okay so let's simplify here a bit if in
the beginning we had four patches now we
would have one patch but note that the
hidden representation has been doubled
in order to increase the capacity to
capture information from a larger region
and then again the whole process repeats
a limited attention span transformer
module is processing the output and this
goes on and on
but each time the attention window is
shifted with respect to the previous
layer so if in the first layer the
attention was limited to neighborhoods
of these regions in the next layer the
regions are shifted like in strided
convolution such that patches that
landed into separate windows in layer 1
and could not communicate
can now communicate at layer 2. then the
resulting patch vectors are again merged
by the merging layer and the whole
hierarchical procedure is repeated
depending on the chosen number of layers
or until no merging is possible anymore
and this was basically it miss coffee
bean has two more comments
[Music]
first regarding the positional
embeddings for the swing transformer we
should say that in principle all kinds
of positional embeddings are applicable
but the authors found that positional
embeddings which are directly added to
the vector representations of the tokens
are not working as well as the relative
position
bias in self-attention a method very
similar to what we presented in this
video
and secondly how good is the swin
transformer
well it outperforms vit and dit on image
classification object detection and
semantic segmentation it is small
objects in object detection where we
would expect to see improvements with
the swin transformer and of course in
semantic segmentation where every pixel
must be labeled however make up your own
mind about the comparisons with the
state of the art because you know like
most of the papers nowadays the
baselines are not necessarily tuned to
be the strongest look at the semantic
segmentation in table three the
swintransformer implementation is
compared to the deity transformer
counterpart but only in its smallest
version a single measurement for one
configuration of d80 is not enough to
see how this all behaves when scaling
the model especially when in terms of
number of parameters the eit small is
even smaller than swin tiny
not really a wealthy opponent for swin
large here right make up your own mind
about this and let us know in the
comments what you think
which vision transformer variant is the
one that determined you to leave the vit
model and use another variant if any
miss coffee bean would be curious about
that and if you like this content do not
forget to leave a like to help with the
youtube algorithm miss coffee bean i'm
curious to know if the youtube algorithm
is transformer based or not miss coffee
bean where are you going i i did not end
this video yet well i guess you ended it
now